I am really feeling the bearded vibe I
love it beard on a man beard is new for
me it is new and is it for work or for
life I good for work but now it's for
life because it serves two purposes it
hides the I'm losing a lot of the
elasticity on my jaw and also it's like
having a pet on your face it's just
never alone never alone what are your
kids think of your beard they're amused
and bemused by everything I do they just
think I'm old that mine - it's super fun
when you work hard so you play a cool
dad and indebted right back but tell us
about the show for people that don't
know I mean the show is basically the
the line is a baby boomers who go bust
and they've got to move in with their
kids and so Fran Drescher and I play
amazingly good-looking grandparents and
we through years of crazy spending and
bad investments we move in with our kids
and I'm having a great time because my
characters like a little bit of a
Lebowski type you know he likes he likes
his special chocolates you know and he's
and he's really crazy in love with her
and so he's relaxing but the parents
have to parent the parents yeah yes that
does happen in life but here's my
question they're rebooting everything
yeah why not reboot wings
[Applause]
you know I do it
most everybody got became gainfully
employed after wings and you know Tim
Daly was the handsomest man in North
America still and Tony Shalhoub Amy a
speck Christa Bernard dim Tran Tom
Hayden church was a great cast great
show we chemistry a great chemistry and
we had so much fun but I'm finally back
like I'm a great sitcoms I mean like the
chemistry this one - yeah they're great
well I've known Fran for a long time
yeah so it's fun to work with her we
both I've known her since the nanny well
yeah okay and then I found out like the
nanny is a global event okay and we went
to these TV kind of fails it was like a
Sony thing right okay and so there were
there were TV affiliates from all over
the world
zoom they saw her people from Tokyo
people yeah Middle East people it was
yes yes yes I watched as well I'm just
saying yes this is crazy you've been in
more than 150 shows and movies Wow just
first performer first the forest yeah
okay so I was in the third grade and I
think yes and we adapted the book where
the wild things are you know Morris and
Max goes to the other and and I managed
to land the supporting role of the
dragon who can be seen on like page
three as Max cosa and that was it and so
I wasn't the lead so I guess I felt
compelled to start ad libbing he felt
competitor fusili I felt competitive I
just felt this not as intense as the
connection I feel this audience just
beautiful
and and I started out living as the
dragon and people started laughing and
it was like a shot and that was the end
or the beginning oh you liked it you
were like that's cool that was that was
you know and at some point when people
didn't respond to a particular scene I
said cut you know I was like seven and I
was getting laughs and and I was that's
amazing on my way to know that early
yeah wow what a blessing well one of
your first acting jobs was actually
dubbing cartoons not dubbing cartoons
but dubbing foreign films I mean when I
was growing up on TV they would have
these kind of you know gladiator films
or like Speed Racer cartoons right Speed
Racer and and so I got a job dubbing
voices in foreign films and if you don't
know what dubbing is it's a and we do an
American TV mu and movies too if the
sound is bad you got to go into a studio
and then redo the sentence like for
instance okay let's let's do it now okay
let's do okay sorry sorry all right so
now that just say this line say the line
Melvin I have to devein the shrimp just
say it
Melvin I have to devein the shrimp right
okay now I heard a sound so we have to
take that out you have to go now
yeah but it's in another language so I
have to find a line to fit the same kind
of mouth flaps okay but I have to put in
a line that's germane to whatever film
I'm I'm trying to so like if I'm gonna
mouth that say Melvin what do you would
you have to say Melvin I have to devein
the shrimp okay so now don't you own
your voice now yeah beep beep beep
there's a monster
[Laughter]
listen you're a terrible peeper
approximate your car that's amazingly
hard let's do it again can't look at you
okay look at me there's a monster in the
living room I walked in and watched my
daughter she's five and I let her just
like pick something on Netflix you know
whatever I was doing something and all
this tonight I'm like why are they
speaking Spanish yeah she watches things
that are from spanner but they'll try
and do them in English like half the
episode is English they do that a lot
still yes yeah part of the problem is
that you know in in different languages
there's different Cadence's yeah rhythm
so that's why if you watch a lot of old
movies you'll hear people talking like
this over there because I fit in
dialogue into foreign mouth flapping oh
my god that's hard and hard not to laugh
obviously that's 11 hmm I know I know
you know I should just steer clear
forget it I feel like I should do it too
much already
yeah don't you you developed another
vocal skill what is it
it's I I can do a cricket a cricket what
did you weigh in Pinocchio or something
like how did you develop a cricket sound
well I just don't because there was a
guy on wings one of the one of the texts
one of the grips named mundo and he used
to very kind of secretly throw in a
cricket sound and it would drive the
sound people insane don't stop you got
it okay so I have to just wet my listen
that's my whistle that is impressive
down subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going